is Ukraine joining NATO going to make
Ukraine more secure or less secure and
what is so terrible about Ukraine being
a formerly neutral country like as
Finland was from 1940 until it joined
NATO and Sweden was and by the way also
Austria is and Switzerland and Ireland I
mean there's lots of European countries
that are formerly neutral but
nonetheless have strong security
guarantees from NATO so I think the
question going forward is kind of an
existential one for NATO as much as for
Ukraine does the Ukrainian logic that
only full membership of NATO guarantee
their security does that theory hold
water or is actually some kind of
association with the West with EU
membership but not actual full
membership of NATO but with strong
security guarantees from NATO Partners
is that going to be feasible and is that
going to be politically acceptable for
Ukraine